[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
are you ready kids
i can't hear you
[Music]
who lives in a swamp right under the sea
who sniffs your own and won't let her
flee
who touches your mom and groped all the
kids
be sure not to tell your dad what i did
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
i was feeling it
wow yeah yeah that was it was good yeah
is that a record thanks for going wow i
haven't seen that
lerpin
almost i said not out of the gate
seriously we gotta be careful because
we're dealing with uh we're dealing with
strom thurman and robert byrd today so
oh oh youtube's saying give me a reason
what you mean those racist democrats who
um yeah yeah maybe change yeah those
slurpers yeah this is uh this is uh
dave search so we gotta be careful with
this one
[Applause]
it was a good slurp yeah thank you uh us
party switch let me talk about that
today that's a big thing because we're
talking about the voting rights now
and everything voting rights black
people can't vote no no
[Applause]
you're thinking anyone can't vote no no
no no that's not it so this is something
that's been one of the most requested
segments uh and i guess we've touched on
it before but we haven't done what the
deep dive as the youngins say you know i
don't know
what you kids do look with your lizzos
and your etunes this is real life this
isn't uh this is no family matters
so we are going to be talking about the
party switch today because voting rights
is a big deal right now and uh you know
there was a civil rights act that
actually took place that really did
matter at one point and really did have
to do with voting rights and uh we're
gonna go back through the records and
it's probably not what you think it was
and then we're also going to go back
through history basically abraham
lincoln through today to address this
issue of the party switch people use it
it's lazy it's incorrect all references
available louder with crowder.com
every day and uh my question to you is
did you ever believe it
out there you guys can comment below
that's the best way to anger the youtube
sun gods is
did you believe before this before you
see the segment so comment now and then
comment below your own comment uh if
your mind has changed uh we talking
about that talking about biden's speech
yesterday oh boy talking about what else
are we talking one of the longest
speeches in in history for president
really conference out that way most of
it was um yes yes bumbling through yes
well he was using his asian dialect so
uh before we get to oh by the way i
should tell you we're going to be here
next week uh-huh dave is going to fill
in host uh one day i'm not letting him
know to keep him on his toes i'm gonna
do that super video on wikipedia we've
got some tricks up our sleeve hey some
things that we've already tested beta
tested no actually tested so hope you
enjoy it wikipedia uh next thursday
that's going to be up uh and if you
don't see this show on youtube
you can just tune in and rumble mug club
weekdays monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern 10 a.m eastern don't let them
cut us off all right
gerald a how are you sir i am doing well
how are you i'm do you know i didn't
sleep for a few days like when people
say that like three hours over the
course of like three four days yeah so i
took someone to help me sleep last night
yeah
obviously completely over the counter
over the counter yes and i don't know
which is worse because then you wake up
and you feel even more tired than if you
just hadn't slept you do yeah why do you
always say that clowns will eat you if
you can't sleep i see that on you i had
one bad experience in college
did a clown try to eat you in your sleep
well in a matter of speaking and we have
of course he's here you know him you
love him he'll be feeling hosting next
week but he'll be at the funny stop and
call hiawaga falls
in cleveland okay
first nations uh name falls january 20th
29th dave linda how are you sir good
ahoy yeah ahoy i'm fine
you should stay ahoy first and then you
know i say how are you and then okay
let's try it again okay
dave lange and first nations two spirit
falls how are you ahoy how about you
[Applause]
we'll work on it
is that wrong
i don't know
i think you need to take more of that
medicine yeah
isn't it funny how we use the term
medicine now when we were kids you've
got medicine with something good for you
and then you realize just what doctors
prescribe oh there's just everything
yeah it's just this is medicine when
you're a kid you think like robitussin
yeah and then you wake up you're an
adult and you're like yeah this is
medicine what is it nine milligrams of
xanax ah that's really what it is yeah i
do well i tell you whatever i take i
just wake up and the tears don't stop
nope just wake up screaming that's why
you get a dirty day that's because you
wake up no and you're still doing lando
yeah it's true that's there's no wake up
and there's just i can't take back what
i've done no you wake up in a puddle of
your own filth going yeah it seems about
right thank you there's one hell of an
ad for valium
i don't even use sheets what's the point
you just take them
before we move on to anything else this
oklahoma pastor he's a tulsa pastor
michael todd
what did i say no no first names i was i
almost wanted to do like an air quotes
pastor okay all right so i thought you
were correct no you're fine i said
pastor you did yes
let me try pastor uh there you go yeah
don't know when to use the air quotes
yeah or as he calls them a reminder of
how to tie his shoes yes
bunny rabbit bunny all in the tree and
he still doesn't get it i don't do that
one notice his velcro
so tulsa passer michael todd spit on one
of his parishioners to demonstrate
how to uh live like jesus christ
changing something and you don't see it
clearly yet what but you hit this guy
oh my gosh is this malcolm and eddie oh
my gosh
oh
no no sir no wow he hawked it no that
was from
diaphragm that was
most people that's a coveted baptism ew
would not face jesus anymore no you're
not jesus and jesus didn't spit people
would do
turn no turn the other cheek turn don't
turn the other cheek just get yeah good
turn away that's the right thing
get lit oh my god get lizzo in between
you two if there is a man behind you
spitting in his hand
it might get nasty
because i don't know how to quit you oh
no
oh now i don't have kovitz
you totally missed that looks like
sunblock and see the responses what did
he swallow a vat of zinc oxide before he
did that
did you see it at least be hydrated gosh
did now do the air quotes make sense now
look at the camera and say bang brothers
this is what he this is to be like jesus
yeah do you know what they think it says
that the most
like thing i've ever seen i'm a little
pissed off drop your cloak and take up
our sword no
all right you know what jesus did he
spit into the mud he did something on
his hand and he made a blind man see
right you think that's what happened
here you just made that guy have to wear
an eye patch for the rest of his life
you probably infected him with something
potentially yes of course i did come on
well everybody who saw wish they were
blind
do you think that guy had an earpiece
where he could pick someone out of the
crowd who he didn't like that's that was
his brother
hold on a second hold on a second there
are three possible scenarios here
brother in the lord right brother
brother or as his actual brother sexual
brother okay like blood blood breath
actually there's four okay i guess yeah
this isn't the ill on omar like you know
hierarchy of brother wow that was gross
i don't i would never let my brother do
that no i can't imagine he's just very
very gross it's theater in church yeah i
get sometimes that's fine but in this
case he was trying to make a point like
oh you see how you're reacting that's
how people reacted when jesus did this
and i'm like not quite no because a guy
could see they're like whoa whoa
yeah yeah no that is
spit in his eyes being curing
the curse of blindness is not a mundane
detail michael that is how you let a hoe
know she's your property without tattoo
money
we backhanded him afterwards oh good
he slapped the spit off of him i got to
keep my jesus hands wrong fast what to
do when jesus slapped mary magdalene he
said [ __ ] i need quarters what does
this pastor cat williams come out yes
did you not see that
[ __ ] ain't got no foot so i'm
gonna kick you in the face
i said play it around don't ask no
questions not jesus no
he he did that look look i know what's
like i know you're waiting the horses
and everything
but can you just make a like a guest
appearance and just say that you're not
with him
he's kind of like i've been making a
guest appearance for three years none of
you seem to care
i know you said nobody knows the time
but i mean it looks right to me yeah
this seems very apocalyptic yeah well
one could hope yeah he's probably just
gonna wait i'm gonna wait till
everything's better just because you
guys have been such jerks yeah yeah
right can you send another flood no no
it's gonna get worse i think he's been
that guy tried to start one you can't
you can't put two of everything on the
boat now have you seen your diet we just
leave mosquitoes off this time
okay and spiders all right well moving
on into uh uh
uh former vice president joe biden so he
uh held a second ever press conference
yesterday i just can't believe that
guy's claiming that that is christ like
it's not no he should spit in mud if
he's trying to like give the correct
presentation but don't do it they said
in mission control they think he also
spit mud too but i mean like there was
it was hanging off his brother so he
he hawked you know what he was doing he
was grabbing like some of the back snot
yeah so like really like you know
everybody in here who's a guy who's hot
to lugia to see how far you could spit
you got to give it some weight and
that's what he did to his brother i mean
maybe if that if his brother was way
younger and he was a priest
actually sorry mission control they were
talking about jesus jesus that's what i
said oh he spit into the mud oh yeah
researchers
make sure you delineate don't uh make
sure if you're referring to actual jesus
versus crazy pastor
i can't tell the difference yeah it's
it's weird well you know jesus when he
returns he's going to be that hobo
peeing down an elevator shaft well at
least if you hear the hobo tell it well
well or or uh joan osborne yeah no we
haven't done it they rejected him at
that time too that's what they try and
say they trying to you know jesus uh if
he were around today you would have
thought he was crazy because of his
radical views no no that's not true at
all yeah that's not true at all he was
entirely lucid if you listen to him he
was logical he spoke sometimes in
parables which were actually pretty
simple maybe reductive to use the term
for all the leftists who like to use the
term nuance to make it sound like they
have a political science degree um which
you probably do it's a useless degree it
is the issue here is no no one would
think he was crazy
he'd probably just have a show on this
network he probably would there we go so
we start spitting on people my gosh that
is just i'm sorry we have to go to biden
but
they totally have to watch that clip
before being right here
i didn't see the pate that he made and
showered his brother
and when the lord said you brother paper
mache is your cheek offered to him your
other cheek
take that pic take that pace make a
[ __ ] hat did his brother lose a
bet
remind me on mug club and it's my
favorite day of the week it's chat
thursday where we take all of your chats
to tell a story about how i use the
power of the church to almost choke my
brother to death right very similar
scenario i've got a loogie story that
wrote that book almost my brother except
my brother was spitting i hope they have
different dads yeah i really i mean if
they're full blood related that's just
a good shot
so
yesterday
you know what i'm saying because uh
on youtube baby biden uh held a second
ever press conference since being in
office it was not
good which brings us to
uh this week in biden wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black
um
the uh uh uh allison harris
thank you mr president speaking of
voting rights legislation if this isn't
passed do you still believe the upcoming
election will be fairly conducted and
its results will be legitimate
well it all depends on
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
remember how we thought not that many
people were going to show up to vote in
the middle of a pandemic
we had the highest voter turnout in the
history of the united states of america
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having a fight about
what to do and not do etc now
whether or not i think that
how can i say this
in a public forum
[Music]
i think
that
he
look i didn't over promise
dude but i have probably uh
outperformed when anybody thought would
happen
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black i think
therefore
i am [ __ ]
i don't know how that was that long with
him flying off the cuff like that yeah i
know yeah just rattling off he's like
robin williams stream of consciousness i
think therefore i'm [ __ ] oh this is
intense alison alison harris kamala
harris sleeping with willie brown what
oh look big penis oh hold on i found my
way to the oval oh look hot lady mask
what if she took off would have stood up
that mask and actually her face looked
like a mask half moon that'd be intense
by the way
yeah i know we like making fun of joe
biden but he did something really bad
there and he's like you know that's
right he spoiled himself well he looked
around the room like he was about to
tell a black joke yes he looked around
he said hey look there's a southern
pastor i'm a southern pastor this is how
the bible i do and then he said i sold
myself pooped
how do i say this terrible thing in a
public forum i just said that out loud
um wait until i do my game it's an
honorable impression i do it every
single time of consciousness
all right sorry go ahead no it's really
bad because he said russia well it
depends on you know if it's like a minor
incursion or something we have to argue
about this and russia's like
oh oh we do a minor incursion by the way
you knew who had a problem with this the
president of ukraine he actually tweeted
out about this and i think we have that
if you can bring that up in just a
second he actually was like look there
are wait the pres the sitting president
of the ukraine is still allowed on
twitter he is i know that sounds like
it's not allowed that miracle spits
doing wonders for him it does if you can
bring it up it's in the honor channel uh
he basically is saying like there are no
minor incursions there are no minor like
fatalities there are no minor people
losing lives and grieving over it
there's no minor countries and by the
way he's like this is from somebody who
is not a minor country like come on how
in the world can you say that that kind
of thing is okay yeah right being able
to invade a minor way yeah you know if
we have to start you know essentially
fighting about they're already fighting
yes
that's like a guy punching you in the
face repeatedly and you're like
so you what you want to fight what are
you saying
he punched you
and then the fight was over and you just
kept hitting him yeah but
it was a minor punch skittles oh my gosh
that's this is scary it really is scary
i can't even read the name of allah and
i'm yeah
i do this for a living
i have to remember the name
how
okay come on joe you're singing again
joe joe somebody yeah what happened to
normal names like ruthie and guterred
yeah and no the girls that are wrong
when i was younger somebody attacked i
know a lady oh god i didn't know
no we used to go to the restroom and
amy's done it up yeah
talk about me
beatrice i once had my way with a
beatrice in the pool yeah all right
we're gonna have to clean that up it's
consensual
it was kind of it was i mean it was
1950s consensual no means yes come on so
what i wanted amy schumer before i move
on here we have a long segment today on
the switching of the parties uh amy
schumer
let me be clear about something here
okay i have never once because sometimes
people say why are you hanging in fact
we've never once just found something
haha you're fat trying it doesn't exist
it's people who demand that you declare
them beautiful brave beautiful healthy
healthy that's the issue we're telling
young people that all of this is good
and it's not if i see people who are
overweight at the gym almost brings a
tear to my eye i i want to see people
taking that first step in the work you
know who had a little bit of a weight
problem
me well it was post-surgery
yeah and when you were younger but uh
when i was younger and that's why i got
to thinking i was referring to younger
and you just yeah crap all over them did
you see the yeah yeah yeah i was trying
to say like you know who had a weight
problem me when i was like 14 and jill
was like no you dude now
six months ago man
it's not seven foot two we all can't
just eat everything all day gerald
stephen in july he had some juicy tits
all right
whoa i watched him run the legend of
stephen's tits
come on have some all right amy schumer
showed off her stunning new body on
instagram
saying i feel good finally
well she feels pretty
no she didn't no no she didn't say witty
did you know she was just in a movie
called i feel pretty a couple years ago
i feel pretty oh so pretty i feel pretty
not witty and fat
i feel good finally it's been a journey
never thought i would do anything but
talk to me after your uterus doesn't
contract for 2.5 years and you turn
40
and uh
there's uh but here's the thing you you
will actually be uh shocked
okay by the before and after picture the
good results good results and i so i
want to give her credit here's the
before picture
uh here's the after picture
[Music]
so she just turned around that's what
happened here is that
she turned around to avoid the pastor's
spit
don't turn around now don't turn around
now come get your blessing you'd have to
do come on get your blessing
go ahead i'm not blind i can see i'm
about to bless you up and that's my i
don't need it i can see a bun i know the
miracle
i'm good come on get your wafer up here
take my body my blood and my spit that's
right that's right this spit gonna turn
into gold
reach back way back come on get you
jesus
[Laughter]
i'm sorry that was actually wrong here's
the correct uh uh before and after
yeah oh it's not a joke
it's not a joke
whatever put a stripe down in that suit
a shark will think she's a hostess
twinkie i appreciate the effort but i
just don't which one's the black one
with the the white swirl which one's the
black it's the
tweet is it not twenty's the white one
what's it called oh you mean uh uh
swiss rolls
where do you mean the ho ho you're
talking ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho
no i think you got it right the ding
dong i think it's the ding dong there's
a ding dong
also known as kingdom it's like pick one
hostess yeah for crying out loud ding
dong is way funnier as a kid so why why
weren't we making fun of those i never
made fun of those well that's because of
how you were raised yeah because you
guys making fun of me you were eating so
many ding-dongs that didn't make a
difference
that's it that's it that's the swiss
roll yeah if you could just put that
down
put that down amy schumer just down that
uh bathing suit he's like the black one
with the creamy inside my neighbor kevin
all right before we move on to the party
switch which i'm looking forward to
getting into uh
this is uh we're talking about very
scary things amy schumer um the new
scream released this weekend actually
just had a had 30.6 million dollars had
a pretty uh that's good had a pretty uh
what dare i say oh dare i say a
frightening success yes oh lord scream
at the box office had a frightening
success
it was spookily successful
a lot of talking in the theater yes lot
of speaking in the theater
but it depends on the neighborhood
or did you get spit on by your pastor
before going into the theater
you're talking
don't miss yourself it is absolutely
horrifying thank you for bringing your
baby to an r-rated film yes
[Laughter]
thank you for using machete as your most
fitting babysitter
[Laughter]
you've run this theater as the
delinquent circus monkey you are far
long enough
all right yes
we've gone through vincent price and
people there's like four prince i don't
care all right so it was very successful
scream uh and i like horror films but we
all know there's obviously it's tough
when you watch a horror film yeah
something about them um especially the
slasher films that just
uh
scream a perfect example seem a little
unrealistic and i think they they could
they could be made they could be
improved i think so
well i'm about to watch a video
really
what
uh some scary movie do you like
scary movies
what's your favorite scary movie
um
i guess
oh an inconvenient truth
[Music]
why do you want to know my name
because
i want to know who i'm looking at
listen ass
no you listen casey you little [ __ ]
how do you know my name
i'm coming in
who's the [ __ ] now
horror movies don't work with a walther
your popcorn's burning [ __ ]
stop speaking in the theater
um sounds like we just winged him yeah
you know he's still there oh he's still
there he might come back i hear there's
gonna be a sequel there could be a
sequel turn that around very quickly
with the screen release uh by the way
you guys can go to waltherams.com yeah
and you can you can't purchase the
firearms obviously online you have to go
to your local uh dealer your local
certified dealer but you can shop for
parts optics lights look yeah they have
the balls to sponsor this show i know
there are a lot of firearm choices that
you have out there this is what i carry
i trust my life with it they're
fantastic and i'm not going to do a lot
of selling you on it just google walther
uh ppq review google walther pdp review
just google bing use that little bent
back paper clip or that purple bonzo
buddy i don't care and try and find
something negative yeah they just don't
have the same kind of a scope for you
know advertising like other people it's
one of the best kept secrets in the
firearm industry i love them they're
fantastic good people right that's what
we want you to do just try it that's all
you need to do try it side by side go to
a gun range try the walther okay uh also
hit the notification bell right now
you're watching right now hit that
notification bell i realize that tim the
toolman has short shorter arms because
he has to reach for the
[Music]
uh
thing
a t-rex
spit on them t-rex looks more like a
giant turkey have you seen this now like
the velociraptor they keep changing the
dinosaurs yeah they're saying that
they're all filled with feathers nobody
would have been afraid of jurassic park
they're not filled with feathers it's
get my dinosaur if it's not the most
comfortable dino you've ever slept on
then this election's been a fraud i was
high on crackled cocaine when i thought
of stuffed dinosaur pillows
they're turning the dinosaurs gay
stephen they're turning them absolutely
turning the dinosaurs gay they're making
dinosaur humanoid hybrids i just saw a
man what look look i know everyone's
going to say that you're crazy
i was hurting my knees when i was about
to pay my drug dealer with my mouth oh
we switched to alex
[Laughter]
there was a there was a there was a man
slash velociraptor walking down
guadalupe i just saw him
it's your dinosaur knee pillow i do
actually want to respect
a lot of uh for mike lindell the guy got
over drugs
i like mike when people always hold it
against someone for the rest of their
life they used that with george w bush
say oh yeah well you did uh you did
cocaine yeah like yeah how'd you figure
out you
you listened to him yeah i did cocaine
this morning i thought i got a second
chance is that not right yeah babies in
the 1920s when they had a cough yeah
that's what they used to do or there was
bears heroin hey don't forget coca-cola
ask your doctor about heroin my baby i
think has acid reflux oh well better do
heroin yes and to really seal it in be
sure to coat his gums with whiskey from
the bottle yes
ask your doctor about wild turkey 101
your baby will sleep sound yes the right
way the doctor's way and here's a box of
chesterfields nine out of ten doctors
recommend them and your life's ridden
stupid flapper hair yes absolutely also
recommend it don't forget to to uh of
course enjoy your 10 minutes of staring
at the sun
every day every day good for the eyes
yes vitamin sun
vitamin
carrots yourself in suntan lotion so you
get more sun when you're outside enjoy
cancer yes we want you to put on more
suntan lotion to prevent your skin from
absorbing sun as your eyes enjoy its
warming rays
staring at the sun may result in gulag
[Laughter]
so uh also here's something that's
pretty big right now uh i don't know if
you guys knew this support for the
republican uh part of the gop just
skyrocketed really this is huge over the
last year the party preference shifted
among americans uh i think this is the
biggest shift uh largest it's a 14 point
swing it's the largest in gallup's
history wow ever in gallup's history in
a one-year period of time yeah so q1
2021 40 uh of uh voters favored
republicans compared to 49 favoring
democrats okay
now it's switched that's q1 q4 same year
47
favoring republicans and 42
that's a 14 point swing
within a year looks like it's going to
be a good year yeah i have obviously
love midterms baby and what are you
going to say now what are you going to
be like oh rashford son but okay how
about gallop well they're not legitimate
snope says maybe
unconfirmed hopefully we'll have record
turnout during a pandemic yes that's a
miracle i will you turns out when you
mail ballots out to everybody they uh
they come back hurry all [ __ ] up it
happened people wouldn't come out and
vote yeah endemic record number even joe
lewis voted yeah yeah okay fraser
marciano literally
hundreds of my dead friends i was
surprised that's what said who's that
jack dempsey voted twice yeah crazy i
just want to be clear he did jacqueline
four times
so did you so does juicer
i just want to be clear biden did say
that we might have reason not to trust
the 2022 election results well if he
loses well no no but i i just i thought
that you couldn't say that no you're not
allowed to say you would get banned and
so i'm assuming that joe biden is now
banned from any social media or media
inspiring an insurrection right i would
assume you would take the second sitting
president off of twitter right yes i
would think kamala should leave
that's just making sure not so much
sitting as lying
are you one of them yeah she's really
the first female president huh mm-hmm
or will be what might be yeah i don't
know how to say that i don't know how to
say it right either how do i say it on a
publicly you don't need to say it
because former vice president joe biden
said huh president harris doing better
than everybody thought him i'm still
alive he hasn't said it dozens of times
if you're if your defense former vice
president yeah your strongest defense is
from the publicly assigned defending
attorney and my cousin vinnie i'm doing
better what is it you're wearing
the
jury yeah
allison
all right so uh let's get into this the
party switch myth because right now the
voting rights uh
is it called the voting rights act the
voting rights bill i think it's
officially titled the voting rights act
because they wanted to they wanted to
sort of dovetailing behind the civil
rights act and they thought
they think so little of
african-americans they thought they
could trick them with a title like i i
thought we had this in like 60 57 and
64. isn't there a civil rights act yeah
yep isn't there a civil rights act too
back well
well it was going to happen but the lead
was getting too old for this [ __ ]
if the weapon 4 should never have been
made
classic they added chris rock and gently
i mean it comes with its perks okay so
while we're on the subject of this um
this is something that you're told quite
a bit okay and this is something that is
one of the most pervasive myths that the
left has used and they've just they've
used it successfully because it's just
sort of gone unchallenged and i think
this is what happens the reason that it
goes unchallenged is because uh often
people are afraid of having to defend
the character of individuals who've
played a role in their party you sort of
see this for example with uh
president trump where people would say
well you know he sent out me i've always
been very clear about the problems that
i have with him but i didn't feel the
need to say it every single time that he
did something good republicans are
afraid because of the character
assassination and this is what they do
when they say look there was a party
switch and they go oh okay i guess you
know strum thurman did some bad stuff so
let's just get off of that because i
have a bunch of strategies telling them
that it's a losing play and it's just
incorrect it's very easy to refute and
i'm going to do it here in about um
let's call it 20 minutes tops okay okay
and references are available at
credit.com i just wish that republicans
grew spine a little bit yeah maybe they
need some good old
pastor spit rub it along the back i
don't think it grows yeah i'll rub it on
your lower back i don't know don't spoil
it all right let's go
so this is what you hear from the left
not from me uh that the the the uh the
party switched after uh the civil rights
movement or during
everyone knows that the parties flipped
during the civil rights movement it's
common knowledge i mean how did the
country go from looking like this to
looking like this so this is the
situation we're starting with democrats
in blue republicans in red this is what
the country looked like at the end of
reconstruction republicans were dominant
in the north and west and democrats in
the south lincoln was a republican and
the states which formed the confederacy
were mostly democrats whenever they
start with everybody knows right right
it's nobody knows the [ __ ] you
spewed this is not correct
everybody knows really
what do you mean you want them to
believe that okay so they show you a map
right good dora the explorer you watched
it good for you who is this guy saddam's
son
yeah that was that was kuze knowing
better i thought so yeah i don't know if
it was hussein no jose works for vox so
uh
not only is it incorrect republicans
let's start with this uh they were the
ones who supported both civil rights act
civil rights act sorry the civil rights
act
57 okay it was the house voted uh yeah
republicans 84 percent democrats 51 huh
okay senate voted yeah republicans 93
democrats 59
in 1964 the 64 civil rights act house
voted yes okay republicans 78 democrats
69. we're getting closer they're making
some progress senate voted yeah
republicans 82 democrats 60. so a
majority of the country okay a majority
of the representatives of the country
yeah supported it but it was
significantly higher i think i mean
you're talking about an average of 20 to
30 something points republicans
supporting the civil rights act back
then now we all i think everyone should
know that
but of course they're going to try and
argue it switched since then that's the
argument that they try and make right
yeah i don't know if everyone did you
guys did everyone out there did you know
that you can comment below i've been
indoctrinated with that yes yeah no no
i'm saying the other way the other way
yeah his point and so this is all good
for me now okay good i'm actually
learning this with a good one else right
after yeah no not that way you can get
them on devry so
uh here's also something to note only
one democrat politician flipped to uh
republican during this time period where
they talked there was about how there
was a switch and we're going to go
through this transition how it's taken
place over the course of time really
over the course of 40 years why it had
taken place
uh and it's not because people became
more racist as a matter of fact it's the
opposite so sometimes you know i see
this a lot from the left or people
online you know who you used to get this
a lot from the atheist community right
that's just a correlation doesn't equal
causation no i know just apply it here
so people were racist
got it and then the map shifted
right that shifted to more republican
and you're just assuming that's because
they became more racist well why the
switch
why would they switch from the friendly
racist democrat party to the unfriendly
always historically non-racist
republican party you think that's the
here's let's let's let's just use logic
here what's the path of least resistance
that's always what they take in politics
you think the path of least resistance
was changing the entire party
yes i've got them right where i want
them to see
we'll lay low for
40 years
so one democrat switched to republican
during this time period that they talk
about i want to get this right strom
thurman great piece of [ __ ] yeah right
strom thurman was a democrat okay uh
famously filibustered the 57 civil
rights act for 24 hours 18 minutes
that's the longest filibuster in history
in history democrat just to be clear
democrat because a lot of people don't
remember the democrats did the
filibustering of the civil rights act
uh there was another racist democrat
robert byrd
he did not switch republican he
filibustered the civil rights act for 14
hours uh one of the longest ever in uh
in history used to be i think in the top
five until recently in the last maybe 20
years and it's right started to happen
more often and i'm using this as a
specific example because people try and
point to strom thurman so he became
republican therefore the party switched
well look far be it for me to defend
strom thurman as a perfect individual
however you do have to understand that
he switched to becoming a republican
okay and once he had become a republican
after
he was one of the first southern uh
senators to hire a black aide yeah to be
clear
and uh authorized the civil rights act
he actually pushed for an mlk uh junior
junior junior to have that out there
junior holiday and joe biden actually
gave the eulogy for him uh obviously
when he passed away and he said
obviously he addressed his past and then
he said oh he came over to the good side
and uh did some really you know good
things that were against what he had
done i'm like oh hold on regnate the
black eight well i don't know maybe that
maybe he was going a little we're not
saying that the guy is perfect but we're
saying that this guy did switch
the only example that democrats point to
right and the point is he became a a
republican became less right well and
the party oh yeah he was racist when he
was a democrat though yeah yes no nobody
is doubting that no one's doubting that
he was a racist listen to joe biden's
words here he said that he came to the
good side later on in life okay well joe
what does that mean because he was a
democrat before he came the only thing
that he'd switched was his party
affiliation to republicans and you're
saying that he came to the good side and
you are the leader of the party that is
supposed to be the friend of african
americans and every minority group in
the united states and you're saying this
guy's a good guy he became a republican
to do it that's joe biden saying it he
became a good guy he became a republican
and then he hired some black aides he
had a change of heart so all references
available a lot with crowder.com the
point is you can't have it both ways now
contrast that with robert byrd who
remained a lifelong democrat worked for
the clan just to be recruited for the
clan so back then retired on clandestine
he was
as his day job was filibustering the
civil rights act and he moonlighted as a
clan grand dragon wizard cyclops and
then became a greeter so yeah then he
became a greeter because he was too old
where do we put birds stick him in the
foyer make sure you wear your hoods
stick him in the clan foyer he came up
with hoods for horses i don't know if
you knew that yeah well here's the thing
the baby had a change of heart yeah uh
except
as recently as 2001 he said this while
still a democrat
on air life tell me my old mom told me
robert
you can't go to heaven
if you hate anybody
what's nice
it's a good start
we practice that
there are white [ __ ] whoa what
i've seen a lot of white bears in my
time we circled back that word
wow you said that on september 10th yeah
hard
i'm telling you it was an inside job
robert bird dropped the n-bomb on live
television twice and they had to cover
it before quick meeting had to cover it
the next day yeah
political silver
guys this is gonna have to be big
jeez
this isn't just you know bury a mistress
on a friday no no it's not a minor yeah
no so uh he ran back to the house while
she's drowning in the lake no not
exactly
miner
so again and i'm not saying that when he
was saying that that means that he was
racist because you need to take it in
context and in context he was pretty
racist
[Music]
you think
and if the wrong two planes went down he
was just a hairs length away from uh
from the presidency under barack obama
as the president pro temp i believe i
heard a white guy say that at an open
mic i'm not even kidding white edwards
and it was the most uncomfortable i've
ever been was it like the crickets in
the audience yes no everybody was like
yes right
spit on them
no it was completely amazing no i was
like this guy's gonna get hurt really
bad after the show and i'm gonna watch
so let's go through kind of now that you
have these individuals who filibustered
the civil rights act you now have the
numbers as to how the civil rights act
uh well 5764 came to be um let's talk
about the switch of southern democrats
to republicans well this is a switch
that had taken place over the course of
about 40 years just to be clear it
happened pretty
slowly before the civil rights act it
was starting and then you sort of
started to see it transition again you
started let's start with this both
parties were racist to begin with yeah
okay at a certain point both to some
degree right some degree and then one
pulled away
one free the slaves i would call that
pulling away yeah
that's our closer
all right spoiler alert
so uh in 1928 for example herbert hoover
was 7 000 votes away in alabama from
winning a majority of former confederate
states he also won 47.6
of the south's popular vote this is in
1928 okay 1928. uh by the way i'm not
saying that he was a great president
just to be clear well hoover towns uh
you know what that one's on him we're
not saying that thurman was an angel
either no no just vacuum after him
that's how much he sucks yeah don't
remind me don't remind me of president
dyson i don't get any swearing in saying
the damn either by 1942 uh southern
democrats were already voting
with republicans on non-racial issues so
let me give you some examples here in
1956 eisenhower who signed the 57 civil
rights act won a majority of the popular
vote in the south
so this is a change that had been
occurring where you could see
republicans becoming uh increasing
here's what happened look let's look at
the we'll go back to abraham lincoln i'm
sure you all know this he was republican
a lot of people didn't but
you watching right now listening this is
remedial for you if you
if you feel bored by this
understand the chasm that exists between
you right now the viewer the listener
and people who are at ivy league
universities yeah because most of them
most of them can't tell you to which
party abraham lincoln belongs okay we'll
go to that later there tim but i know he
was getting ready for me to queue it up
because i did a video 12 years ago at
berkeley oh um but
understand that abraham lincoln right
you're talking about he was a wig at one
point basically right the creator
effectively or you would say the
republican party certainly uh a pioneer
yeah i think that's fair yeah trying to
couch my words here to be careful but
you know what abraham lincoln noted
republican freed the slaves however you
do have to look at it
it's sort of like now when people let's
say you're on a road trip okay and the
kids say are we there yet are we there
yet well keep in mind at that point
when they freed the slaves right prior
to the emancipation proclamation there
was no there yet yeah right so in other
words there's no blueprint there's no
road map you had an abraham lincoln so
you had a republican party from its
inception that was really created out of
struggle it was born the struggle was we
just cannot reconcile our constitution
and the ownership of human beings that's
the creation of the republican party and
then you can see why this started
changing why there was an evolution why
the south started changing after while
we're talking about the civil war and
you see this party growing and
increasing an influence it's it's tough
for us to look back and go well there
are now we have racists and non-racists
back then you wouldn't be able to define
a racist to anyone yeah
okay because that was the baseline so
hopefully that helps you contextually so
uh now what they will tell you is of
course this is well this happened uh and
then the party switched and now they
kind of shy away from that and another
argument is but you know what it does it
doesn't matter because right now the
democrats are the ones uh they're the
ones championing civil rights so uh
checkmate the democratic party was once
the party of white supremacy supporting
slavery and the ku klux klan
today's democratic party believes that
government has an important role to play
in society it fights against economic
inequality it advocates policies that
battle racial and gender discrimination
must you be gay to work for vox why does
yeah why does it have to be gender
you're talking about race you're like
racial and gender discrimination we're
piggybacking off that one okay
what they're doing is they're trying to
get these people to vote for them yes
exactly it's very hard to see through
this tricky tricky plot this rules
pretty much okay
let's be clear democrats have been
taking advantage of black people
specifically all now it's extended to
all minorities but specifically black
people since slavery let's go to the
people who their examples who might have
been the strongest champions of civil
rights uh lbj the great society okay
this is something that a lot of people
may not know about i did a video on
detroit it was my first on location
super video i believe back in 2009 where
we talked about great society we talked
about model cities program we talked
about jerome kavanaugh first mayor of
detroit 61 all the way up to today now
uh the great society incentivized and
increase the number of single-parent
households you've heard the term baby
mama this goes back to great society
there was a financial incentive to not
be married to not have a father in the
household uh this created a massive
welfare state kept people more reliant
on government aid it de-incentivized
work uh and now of course we take that
to today where you look at that okay
this is let's call that soft bigotry and
we'll get to the hard bigotry in a
second
you thought robert byrd was bad but the
soft bigotry was hey you know what uh if
you vote for us um
we'll give you two checks hey if you
vote for us we'll give you more we'll
create this massive welfare state hey
you know but just don't get married
it's better if you have two single
households and having a joint household
and there was an incentive for people
and he sought out cities detroit was
also to be supposed to be sort of
coinciding as a model city the model
cities program is is detroit a uh a
model city now uh by his standard yeah
so you have the soft expectation the
soft bigotry well do we see that today
let's look at affirmative action we see
this with the democrats today that's a
civil that that's championing civil
rights by saying black people are so
incapable of getting into university
that we need to create a quota and by
the way keep asians
out these are the the consequences of
low expectations of viewing people
simply as votes to be garnered is hey
we're going to create a welfare state
that's great we'll give people free
stuff if we get them to vote for us well
that hurts them hey affirmative action
universities and then you see black
students dropping out at rates that are
exponentially higher than their uh
their counterparts why
because you've set them up to fail but
you sure get to pat yourself on the back
what else do we have voter id well
here's another example so i don't i
can't think of an example
in my lifetime
that is more uh more of a backhanded
insult than saying that black people
can't procure identification yeah that's
the basis of the new
voting rights act it's black people
people shouldn't have to have id it
hurts minorities
can you think of an example of
privileged white pricks speaking for
black people more clearly than today and
black people don't agree just to be
clear 73 do not agree it's not it's not
even close
they also have heritage in america that
dates back to most americans when you
think about it there's no reason they
wouldn't have id to treat them like
they're a new class when they helped
build the country makes absolutely no
sense good point yeah were you about to
say something there jill i would say i
mean this with lbj's incentives he was
basically saying like a lot of people
say these are perverse incentives that
he created i'm like no no no no he was
making people dependent that was his
entire goal because look at the amount
of money that you get the amount of
money that you get is not enough to feel
great and and live a lavish lifestyle
it's just enough it's just until now
it's just
you're hungry you're not starving right
under lbj's plan right that's what he
did and it's not you're not so hungry
that you're gonna go out and make a
change you're just comfortable enough in
the mess that you're in to not make a
change well there have been uh there
have been people uh i'm trying to think
i i don't wanna misquote anybody but
there was there were some presidents of
sports organizations one of them might
have been dana white with ufc but um
this has also been used to be fair uh
it's been used to corrupt places like
boxing where they basically underpay
fighters or they end up taking financial
advantage of them but it's been said too
that with athletes and you see this with
a lot of athletes uh pragmatically
speaking you have people who've been the
heads of sports organizations who have
said you know the problem is someone
comes in who's really hungry coming in
from university they get tens of
millions of dollars
and it's real now they don't care and
it's hard to incentivize them right and
so a lot of the time you these people
want these athletes under their thumb
and pay them enough so that they they
kind of reap the benefits but they're
still hungry i think the old quote is
marvin haggler it's hard to get up at
five in the morning to go for a run when
you're waking up in silk sheets and so
lbj understood this and exactly so the
democrats were they were saying we're
going to give you just enough but just
enough to make it to the next check so
that and you know where that check is
coming from by the way that's how you
condition dogs just to be clear how do
you condition this is how you train dogs
is how you train a lot of animals but
certainly dogs if you want to condition
them positively you reward behavior with
a treat but guess what you don't do you
typically don't do that
right after a meal right you give them a
treat you don't fill them up on a treat
because they need to know where the next
treat's coming from it's all right you
get this now go over there okay sit you
get this treat i know it's it's not
enough you're not you're not starving
you have enough but okay now lay down no
no treat yeah here's a check no wait
hold on a second make sure are you
voting right okay here's another one but
just enough right okay here's a welfare
state okay here are ebt cards okay this
is how it works this is how you
condition people to become control
here's eviction moratorium even though i
know it's not legal and by the way this
is not a new theory right this is
written down in proverbs in scripture if
a man does not work he does not eat and
it paraphrases basically to say
let his belly be his guide when he's
hungry enough he'll get up and go work
so that he can eat
that's the kind of motivation we need
because we're at our heart we're selfish
lazy people and if you allow us to live
there
it produces nothing good
i try to give my dogs ebt cards if they
don't work
a choking hazard is that what it is
because they don't even care what's the
problem you just said let if if a man
does not work he does not eat let his
belly be his guide i think that's all in
one but one hell of a
too many people's bellies are their
guides right now
when i use my belly compass yeah bad
things happen
and toilets
so here's also lbj that's the soft
racism and you see it through policy and
i hate that term but that's the term
that we're sort of using here because
it's a term that i know you're probably
more familiar with
soft when it's not hard right here's the
hard racism from lbj historians ronald
kressler and doris goodwin
these are all quotes on the record uh
these are lbj quotes these negroes
getting pretty uppity these days and
that's a problem for us here's another
quote now i've got to do something about
this we've got to give them a little
something just enough to quiet them down
not enough to make a difference and i
want to give you another quote because
this is something back when uh you know
vladimir.com and now you can see the
references there but back we were mainly
writing articles before this show was
the size that it was a big part of what
we did was writing daily articles
and uh it was tough to find a source for
this quote from lbj this had been
circulating around
and so we ended up doing a story i think
a long time ago on snopes not fact
checking this horrible quote that you're
about to hear from lbj not saying it's
false but doing everything in their
power to avoid acknowledging that it's
true because again these quotes from
these historians that you just heard no
one doubts them okay who presented these
quotes these people are legitimate you
have uh robert kressler right these are
the previous quotes okay and stump's
like okay this was said now
snopes wrote the following
quote as unproven even though the other
ones we know are true from the same
sources
uh
robert kressler wrote that and i just
will it says i'll have them n-words
voting democrat for 200 years i would
quote accurately but i'm not robert byrd
so i can't get away with it i am so
happy
now the snopes rationale for
fact-checking this quote to be clear
like they didn't say it was false right
yeah but they said they can't prove that
it was true this is their rationale it's
a circling back to the quote which we
started it wouldn't have been entirely
out of character for lbj to have said
something like i'll have those n-words
voting democratic for 200 years but on
balance we have to question its
authenticity now keep in mind this is
the same snopes that said illon omar uh
did not marry her brother sorry unproven
unproven unproven here's a marriage
certificate unproven here's the name
when it comes to incest unproven means
yes yes can i paraphrase snopes that
sounds like him yeah
i mean it seems like something she would
do
i mean if i'm being honest but i'm
usually not i mean given what he said
before this really is that's not as bad
as what he said otherwise so yeah it's
probably yeah you know listen i mean we
can't we can't all be oh i forgot you
never made a mistake
some of us marry our brothers listen he
said for 100 years stephen that is a
false quote snope said we couldn't prove
it true and politifact rated it as i
forgot that you're mr perfect
i mean come on it's not like we watched
him do it yeah that wasn't there right
like i will fill out their votes for
them for the next two i only saw him
kiss yeah they only kissed a hug
yeah what about their uh what about ill
on omar and her uh her non-brother son
oh yeah i have no idea
just jumping through a fiery hoop yeah
what is this ferris bueller when sloane
kisses her father picking him up at the
beginning
omar i'd like to have a couple of words
with you by god so
lincoln
i fact-checked you and then you insult
me what the hell's the matter with you
omar anyway so rooney here's another
argument that they make that lincoln
emperor would have been a democrat today
right you hear this a lot you'll see it
at hufflepuff references available at
loudoutwithcredit.com uh uh of course i
say that this is incorrect but don't
take my word for it
party of abraham lincoln don't ever you
know i say it all the time everyone
thinks that abraham lincoln was a
democrat
abraham lincoln was a great republican
okay so here's something
let me try and simplify this okay um do
you remember how in the uh 2008 election
john mccain was trying to distance
himself from george w bush because he
wasn't the best president people weren't
happy with him right so it was like hey
we're going to endorse it he was like
that's all right
so
if the party today the republican party
today if you say they switched this is
the premise we just showed you from from
vox and what was it the one who's truth
before whatever it is look out truth the
guy yeah everybody knows i don't know
another gay guy in a plaid shirt
so
i don't say that as a pejorative no
descriptive oh it absolutely is if i
were to say look if i were to say the
guy and the other you'd be like oh which
clip gay guy plat shirt you go oh i got
it you had to include pledges right so
if
the party switched from abraham lincoln
okay the acknowledgement right the
premise from the left is abraham lincoln
republican freed the slaves but then it
switched
why would today's racist party be
clamoring to continually identify
themselves with abraham lincoln why
would donald trump say in other words if
you believe that donald trump is a
politician right who just wants to say
what people want to hear
why is the current republican assuming
that all other current republicans like
the republican who freed the slaves it
would be a losing strategy if he was
saying it to a room of racists does that
make sense it would be booed yeah and
jeered so uh and trump does have a point
though that they often try to claim the
left they try to uh i mean a lot of
people believe this this was i think
back in 2009
and i just to be clear i hate the kind
of jaywalking gotcha stuff because you
can do that with anybody
however the context here was i never
planned on doing a video asking the
party of uh abraham lincoln yeah it came
up this is before the term virtue
signaling existed okay it came up
because i asked people who their
favorite president was and everyone well
most people invariably answered abraham
lincoln yeah and so it was a simple
thought was like
okay which to which party do you belong
and then they couldn't answer this these
are current students at berkeley or as
the left refers to you uh their best and
brightest i guess that's kind of a
cliched answer but i'll say abraham
lincoln abraham lincoln i'm gonna go
ahead and say lincoln abraham lincoln
abraham lincoln abe lincoln was easily
the most popular
naming the party of the old dude with
the beard and hat
a little more daunting and uh to what
party did abraham lincoln belong
wig
um
yes abe lincoln was not a wiggly
yeah i'm not sure weaker weaver yeah
um back then i believe he was a
republican but
that was nominally a republican
well she's basically right yeah
nominally a republican yeah wait hold on
a second do you mean uh first off by the
way to be clear was a wig and then said
i'm going to create something
uh republicanism what year was that 09
nominally it's like ah you know edison
nominally something light bulb i don't
know yeah but she's gross now
benjamin franklin nominally likes to fly
kites
democrats loved slavery so much they
tried to form another country and have
that as the platform yeah you had to
remove their statues i mean
do you understand the argument that
you're making do you think that just
goes away yeah no they just found a
better way to control you they should
have asked her what anomaly means and
she'll be like i don't know well
nominated speaking nominally means they
said it and i said it
something and that's about the end of my
answer
i don't know
well i think in that same video i'm not
sure if that's that same video this is
back in 2009. so i've been doing this
you know louder with the louder with
crowder i think started 2009 2008 been
around for a while
in a negative way well i just read like
it was great because it wasn't this
exact show right it was you know back
then there were no podcasts like when we
started this podcast again there was no
there yet but the latter was crowder
episodics these started like in i want
to say 2009 2008. you look so young
thank you
i mean now uh
back then you looked pretty bad
[Laughter]
it's always it's it's just one of life's
cruel tricks that you lose your your
baby fat once you grow your beard but
it's immediately gray
it does go great pretty fast there
should be a rule that you shouldn't be
able to have gray hair and pimples i
hate that i lost all that baby fat
oh baby
um i look like an old baby
the baby collecting social security that
one belly
so um i think in that same video where i
did a berkeley series
uh
it might be that one but you can search
go back to through this if you're on
youtube right now uh and by the way if
you're on youtube smash that like button
right now that's also something that
helps and you can comment below we're
gonna wrap this up and go to mug club
uh
in 2009 also i was in class and they
didn't have hidden cameras back then
uh-huh uh so i was literally i mean with
a baseball cap and the equivalent to you
know four gopros yeah in it it's like a
trucker cap
you had to say i'm sitting in there
you know one of those picture cameras in
a in a coffee cup that would last about
35 seconds yeah but you can see some
footage where a teacher is teaching
their students at berkeley i'm in the
classroom this is before hidden camera
stuff existed on youtube teaching them
that uh we meaning americans went into
the old world and captured and enslaved
people and took them to the new world
and i asked her just a simple question
this wasn't a big class and back then i
looked young enough right dave
uh so it did
um i asked i asked the professor i said
hey yeah how many of these um
slaves in the united states were as you
said stolen you know captured versus
sold and
purchased sold into slavery from the old
world she said that's a very good
question teaching the class and i don't
know the answer to that well it's the
lowest number you'll see is 80
and it's as high as 95 depending on the
estimates that you use what's the name
of that guy uh who was did the beer
summit i always forget his name the the
black guy with the crazy hair fred
rogers no the black guy with the cr
uh uh uh someone will fight you at the
beer summit at the white house remember
that guy don't with the cop clarence
williams so he's sitting there my
brother on cnn that guy i always forget
his name anyway he estimated that it was
90 i think 96 percent
you're talking about yeah they're
getting his name but uh this the lowest
number is 80. what did it narrow it down
did you find it yeah
no not don king donald trump that's a
fight promoter
what dude
black guy
it autocorrected it's like is it colonel
something uh not colonel something it's
uh gosh yes it's colonel sanders i can't
remember his name i cannot remember the
guy's name i'm horrible i know i can
picture his face in my head there was a
beer summit with barack obama because
this guy got this was the kind of the
first looks like clarence williams iii
though i know he did yeah i i know yeah
yeah from he hails from the hood he was
the first guy who got arrested by a
police officer and everyone made it
about race and so then barack obama
invited him to the white house there was
a beer summit and one of them prefer one
of them preferred blue moon i can
remember all of these things and i know
that's 100 right but i can't remember
his name isn't that insane at least if
you meet him you'll know what drink he
wants yeah well i think it was a white
guy who preferred blue moon he was about
45 man
no i don't blame him
anyway someone will fund the name will
get it on mud club but the point is this
was a guy who was like a black
liberation theologist right he's a
professor
wait cornell west courtney
see i was like colonel cornell west and
you
type in clarence williams and tell me if
they don't look the same the third and i
just mean i don't mean like in a race
they just some people look like that
right you look like tom hanks didn't you
go on a show with him one time and he
got up in the storm was that cornell
west no no no no no no no no when you
clear west is very highly educated no no
i know did you skype in with somebody
and he said brother crowd and you were
like jokingly said i am not your brother
and then this guy i swear to you this
was i think up in michigan you skyped
into an interview and this guy
threw his head got mad yeah he got mad
he looked like cornell west if it wasn't
cornell west mate remember a guy walked
off yes
how can you not remember this i don't
remember this this is hilarious we got
to find this at some point all right i
think maybe the guy was joking anyway i
think you're talking about cornell you
had really pissed him off he was very
seriously angry cornell eastern
conference that's what it was yes okay
different guy cornell
the point is i remember him estimating
cornell west i think if you type in this
right now you know we'll take your
chance i want to say that he said
or he gave an estimate that the amount
of slaves who were sold as opposed to
captured was 90 something percent i
think he might have said as high as 96
wow so you guys can find that reference
we'll i'll show it on mug club but
everything else and by the way this is
uh
this is there will be a bonus to who
everyone there
in the mission control on mug club who
fact checks everything that i just said
cornell west was arrested by a police
officer then barack obama had them to
the white house for a beer summit one of
them preferred blue moon and also find
that number of the estimate from cornell
west about how many of them were sold
into slavery versus captured these are
the things that i remember it's bizarre
and i can't remember a name it's like
tammy i'll be sitting like i remember
you went to uh you went to heritage
academy high school you were an honor
student i remember you were in the
international program you did figure
skating i also remember that your hair
was blonde then you dyed it red i
remembered that and then i was like well
yeah but what's my name
i don't know tlc
so left eye west yes
uh lincoln let's go back to lincoln
we'll close with this he was a firm
believer in personal liberty and the
constitution let me read you some quotes
uh and that's ironic i'm using snopes
now he said in all that the people can
individually do as well for themselves
government ought not to interfere we the
people are the rightful masters of both
congress and the courts not to overthrow
the constitution but to overthrow the
men who pervert the constitution yeah so
this is what i want to leave you with
the shift in the south was something and
it's so funny because i i often
encourage being reductive
i encourage you to be able to if there's
an old saying i don't remember who said
it so uh this is not my i can't remember
the name of who said it uh there's no
saying that if you can't explain if you
can't give your pitch if you can't
explain the concept make your case in 30
seconds or less you have no business
making it so i think it's important i
think it's a valuable skill not to take
simple topics and make them complicated
but to take complicated topics and make
them simple why i believe that any skill
so i think this is the difference
between sort of virtue signaling and
reading your resume versus a an actual
skill comparing for example trade
schools versus a gender studies degree
how do you say one is a value it
benefits others
right
a useless skill uh or a useless degree
or in this case a useless gift where
people want to
pretend to be let's say hyperly
intelligent it's a gift for yourself if
you can take a simple topic and make it
complicated so fewer people understand
it and then use the term nuance to cover
your tracks you're not helping anybody a
valuable skill is somebody really really
smart who's able to take it and boil it
down so ironically as someone who says
there's nothing wrong with being
reductive i actually value that skill
more than creating something
or making it more complex than it needs
to be in this situation look
it the the transition of the south to
republican took place over a long period
of time it took place uh over a long
series of issues
and i encourage you to go check all
references again at the website the link
is in the description
however so it is more nuanced but to
simplify it
republican party was created
was created to end slavery that's a big
reason for it not the only reason but
the republican party was born out of
okay
inner turmoil con inner turmoil conflict
that sounded like a southerner oil oil
oil no it was born out of conflict it
was born out of struggle it was born out
of a conscience of look we cannot do
this we can't keep people as property
and then talk about property rights and
talk about individual rights that's how
it was created that was the reason that
it existed and you look through history
okay they supported civil rights you see
that and then today you still see
democrats
enacting
legislatively the kind of soft bigotry
of low expectations that you saw from
lbj that you saw a long time ago and
today you still have donald trump you
still have ron desantis you still have
today's republicans invoking abraham
lincoln so they were anti-slavery they
were anti-racist back then and the
people today still want to have him on
their money and get his endorsement
there's a lot that happened in between
just don't buy the premise from the left
because if you just fact check a little
bit just a couple of points
it falls apart and uh by that i mean
actually fact check not a snopes
illinois may or may not have banged uh
her brother okay right now leave a
comment we're about to go to mug club
and take your chats youtube piss off
[Music]